humility is a really good sign
of somebody
who's traveled the long road and been
humbled by how little they know
so some of the best people in the world
at whatever the thing they've spent
their life doing are the ones that are
ultimately
humble in the face of it all so like
just being
humble
how little we know even if we travel a
lifetime
i do like the idea
i mean treating sort of uh like what is
it psychonauts like an expert witness
you know people who have traveled
with the help of dmt to another place
where they uh
got some deep understanding of something
and their insight is perhaps as valuable
as the insight of somebody who ran
rigorous psychological studies at uh
princeton university or something
like those those psychonauts they have
wisdom if it's done rigorously uh which
you can also do rigorously within the
university within the studies now with
the with psilocybin and those kinds of
things yeah that that's
fascinating still probably the best one
of the best works on mystical experience
there's
the chapter in william james has
varieties of religious experiences
and most of it is um just a
psychological study of trying to define
the characteristics of mystical
experience as a psychological type
but at the end he considers the question
if you have a mystical experience is it
rational to trust it to trust that it's
telling you something about reality and
he makes an interesting argument he says
if you say no
you're kind of applying a double
standard
because we all think it's okay to trust
our
normal sensory experiences
but we have no way of
getting outside of ourselves to prove
that our sensory experiences correspond
to an external reality we could be in
the matrix this could be a very vivid
dream uh you know you could say or we do
science but
a scientist only
gets their data by
experiencing the results of their
experiments and then the question arises
again how do you know that corresponds
to a real world so he thinks there's a
sort of double standard in saying
it's okay to trust our ordinary sensory
experiences but it's not okay for the
person on dmt to trust those experiences
it's very philosophically difficult to
say
why is it okay in the one case
and not the other so i think there's an
interesting argument there but i would
like to just defend experts a little bit
i mean i agree it's very difficult but
especially in an age i guess where
there's so much information
i do think it's important
to have
some
protection of
sources of information academic
institutions that we can trust and then
that's difficult because of course there
are non-academics who do know what
they're talking about but like if i'm
interested in knowing about biology you
know you can't research everything
so i think we have to have
some sense of
who are the experts
we can trust the people who've spent a
lot of time reading all the material
that people have read written um
thinking about it
having their
their views torn apart by other people
working in the field i think that is
very important and also to protect that
from conflicts of interest there is a
so-called think tank in the uk called
the institute of economic affairs who
are always on the bbc as
experts on economic questions and they
do not declare who funds them right
so
we don't know who's paying the piper i
think you know you shouldn't be allowed
to call yourself a think tank if you're
not totally transparent about who's
funding you so i think that's the and i
mean this connects to pan psychism
because i think the reason people
you know
worry about unorthodox ideas is because
they worry about how do we know when
we're just losing control or losing
discipline so i do think we need to
somehow protect
um
academic institutions as
sources of information that we can trust
and you know in philosophy there's
there's um you know there's no not much
consensus on everything but you can at
least know
what people
who have put the time in to read all the
stuff
what what they think about these issues
i think that is important
you